hello and welcome to the agenda we're
here in Strasbourg but let's take a look
at what's happening next week in
Brussels starting things off it's over
to the civil liberties committee an
anti-corruption report by the Commission
says that we lose 120 billion euros in
revenue a year and when the biggest
concerns is the business political Nexus
Romania and Bulgaria remain under heavy
EU monitoring because of high levels of
corruption but our worst offender is
Greece it shares equal footing with
China on transparency international's
corruption index coming in at a great
number 80 author of the report Cecilia
Malstrom the EU commissioner for home
affairs sits down with mep s on
wednesday second up is a votive beefed
up for protection of information in the
wake of the NSA hacking rao majesty
voted on include adopting a data package
protection for whistleblowers concluding
data sharing agreements with the US and
suspension of safe harbor the committee
votes on the draft report on wednesday
securing water rights for all was the
aim of the first successful citizens
initiative it managed to get the million
signatures across seven member states to
its petition the trigger to getting the
Commission to take action the aim of the
proposal is to guarantee water and
sanitation for all and to stop
liberalisation of water services Monday
will see the first public hearing take
place
the all inclusive package tour holiday
can be a real great way to travel your
flights your hotel everything is taken
care of by one company so they've been
some real horror stories travelers
getting stranded at airports because the
company they use went bust overnight
appalling accommodation and amenities so
it's time for the EU to take action on
the table our proposals to guarantee
flights for stranded passengers
information on good travel companies to
book with and better passenger rights
the internal market committee votes on
the draft report on Tuesday and as all
we have that its agenda take care and
enjoy the week